Today's going to be a little bit different
with the video
Take the front? Okay
because
something quite amazing has happened
I've been trying to sell a business for 2 years
and a lot of times people ask
you know, how do you fund this travel?
How do you make these videos?
It's because I've had another business
that's funding me
I have to sign off on documents today
They have to be notarized
and then shipped out FedEx
So, Hamid Singh
my faithful lieutenant is helping me along the way
My phone's not working here for some reason
And so, we're gonna sign these docs
Hopefully, Indian documents
notarization work in the United States, I'm not sure
I'll find out in a few days
So, we're gonna go through this process
A little behind the scenes legal process
of what this is like in India
if I can get the camera in there
and then...
talk a little bit about business
talk a little bit about
running a business from abroad
how you can fund international lifestyle
How you don't have to live near
where your money comes from
So, a lot of people ask how it's possible to
to travel like this because travel takes money
and a lot of people think because you're traveling
you're not working
because you're out of geography you're normally in
you're away from your workspace, whatever that is
Okay, couple myths here
Traveling cost less for me
than living in San Francisco
Like going to all these places
even with the airline tickets
hotels
my costs are less than just staying at home
Okay, so that's one myth disproved
Secondly
You can work from anywhere now, that's the thing
I have a service based...
I'm about to say I had which is cool
but I have service based business
And I realized a long time ago in the States
average job, 50 weeks a year
you're gonna work then you got Thanksgiving, Christmas
You're not going anywhere in the world
It's gonna be very hard
We never traveled growing up
my father worked 51 weeks a year
so I realized, okay, I gotta figure something out
where I can remove myself
and I read this book
called "The E-Myth"
and there's one called "E-Myth Revisited"
and that really taught me a lot
about structuring a business
where you work on the business not in the business
where you set up all the systems
and it can work outside of it, so
my detailing business
is structured that way where I can live abroad
I can travel
I just need a Wi-Fi connection so I can run it
Sounds all easy
There's all sorts of psychology
running a team of people from across the world
You have to structure it in a way where it makes it
really good for them financially
and a good ecosystem
where they don't want to go somewhere else
don't want to take advantage of you
I could talk for days about that
but
the point is
you don't need to be in the ones and zeros
you don't need to be doing an app
being a digital nomad
in tech
You can actually do a service-based business
and live a very free global lifestyle
Is it easy? No, I'm not saying it's easy
It took a lot of work to get to this point
but I've been...
I've been absentee owner for about 7 years now
and it allowed me to start doing what's true inside me
which is making these videos
What I've learned in this journey is
there's a lot of value on headspace
even though I've been an absentee owner
my head is a lot there
my...
My time is there, you know
writing e-mails
checking up on things, whatever it might be
and it's not let me go all in on the video
because I'm really in two worlds
so by selling this business
it's just gonna free up that headspace
and give me a financial runway
where I can really go hard at the video
I've only been doing this regularly for like
5 month (FILMED FALL 2019)
YouTube videos
but it's starting to work
and I'm starting to see you can make money
even just through ad revenue
there's like...
there's possibility to make money
Just did the Saudi series
that's doing pretty well
and it's bringing in a little money
but the goal is
down the road
to have this platform and this channel
to build a tribe of people that
you know, can connect and relate
to the message I'm giving which is
"People aren't politics"
The world is pretty much open
most places are safe
most people are cool
Of course, there are exceptions
but it's a contrast from the news narrative
that we're fed
That's what I get fired up about
Thank God for Hamid Singh
Without him, it would have been
impossible to make this happen today
cus there's one notary place I believe
in the city
and my phone stopped working
my cellphone plan
I don't know what happened
I have Global Plan
It's not working in the city
it works everywhere else
so he's really really helping me out
And this is like a government office?
Okay
Cool
Namaste
Namaste, sir
How are you?
I'm well, thank you
Hello
Namaste
Yes
This is where we do it?
This is the boss?
Notary
Okay
The notary
Great
Okay
We just need the first two pages
notarized
Good name what?
My name, Peter Santenello
And then the rest I've signed
Can I see your passport?
Thank you so much
Bye-bye
Bye
This has to be out in a couple of hours
for to get into FedEx
It's Friday
It's gotta be in the States by Monday
In India, it's quite normal to be in tight spaces
It's quite normal to be in tight spaces
you got over a billion people, what do you expect?
And even in this relatively small city
It's packed in pretty tightly
Now, off to FedEx
the last stop to get these documents off
So
another thing I wanted to mention was
it's all about burn
and what I mean by that is like
what are you spending, what are you making?
And
I made a conscious decision
3 years ago
to move to Ukraine
I had some good friends there
I've been there, I liked it
but
I spent 1/3 of the money
versus San Francisco
and the world is very close
Istanbul is now an hour and 45 minutes away
versus 13 hours and 10 time zones
Everywhere is close now
I can get to the Middle East easily
I can get to Europe easily
even India
you know, it's much closer than than
travelling from San Francisco
So, setting life up that way
where I can conduct business
well, remotely
and then sort of
you know, gradually getting this other
ship into the harbor
let's say, the video work
YouTube videos
and stepping over on that other ship
and that ship's about to sail off
right now
and the other ship's gone
So, it was a process
nothing happened overnight
Maybe it could've happen quicker
maybe it could've happened more slowly but
anyways, it was a process
I think that's a fallacy a lot of people have
It's easy to look great online
It's easy to look like everything's just rocking all the time
S**t, I'm making travel videos
it all looks like fun
It all looks like it was just like presented to me
No, it's like...
been a bit of a grind in a good way though
and I think it's important to have that
I think it's...
It shouldn't all be fun, it shouldn't all be easy
cus it's not
Zero complaining going on here
I'm just saying it's like...
These are the conscious choices
I made for a lifestyle
and there are pros and cons with that
and what works for me
most likely won't work for you
and I think that's the case with everyone
I don't think anyone can give anyone else
direct advice on how they're to live their life
because everyone's different
So I'm just explaining my journey
and it's gotten quite wild
I gotta say like life has gotten quite interesting
when you're driving around India
trying to take care of some business matters
so you can be off to the Pakistani border
later on in the day
This is what I like
It's not for everyone
It's not the comfort road, that's for sure
If I was wanted to be comfortable
I would just stay in the States
States it's probably
arguably the best place just to be comfortable
you know, materially have space
less things in your way
consumption is easy there
but
to me, it's like comfort, and then what?
Just be comfortable?
And then...
What else is there?
What this to me is discomfort in many ways
but excitement and adventure
Like today is an adventure
Here we are
Here we are at FedEx, DHL
So, here are the documents
America Tuesday
$24?
It seems very cheap
to be honest
So, you take the package like this
then you send it off and put it in the FedEx?
And then you send me a tracking number?
Yeah
Great, thank you
It's your assistant?
Yes
Doing a great job
And this...
Okay
Bye-bye
There we go
Tuesday, stateside
The deal should be done
The money should hit the account Wednesday
and it gives a nice runway for the next stage of my life
to figure out
how to make money another way
YouTube ad revenue is unless you're a monster channel
I don't think it's something to rely on
so
Exciting times, I'm pumped
Thanks for coming along on that journey